hello and welcome everybody welcome to
the Macmillan Center for International
and area studies I'm Ian Shapiro that
the current director and I'm delighted
to have the opportunity today to be the
host and introduce John J Mishima who's
this year's Henry L Stimson lecturer he
is the Wendell Harrison Distinguished
Service professor of political science
and co-director of the program on
international security at the University
of Chicago professor Mearsheimer has
written extensively about security
issues and international politics more
generally he's published five major
books including perhaps the one he's
best known for the tragedy of the grave
of great power politics which came out
in 2001 and a second edition - in 2014
which won the Joseph let Gold Book Prize
and has been translated into eight
languages and then with Steve Walt
in 2007 the Israel lobby and US foreign
policy which became a New York Times
bestseller and has been translated into
twenty four languages he's also written
many articles in academic journals such
as international security and in more
popular outlets such as Foreign Affairs
and the London Review of Books he's won
a number of teaching awards and became a
member of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences in 2003 he's here today to
give three lectures from me from his
forthcoming book of Stimson lectures
that'll be published next year by Yale
University Press under the general
heading liberal ideals and international
realities today is the first of the
three its title is the roots of liberal
hegemony his next lecture which will be
on Wednesday will be entitled the false
promise of liberal hegemony and
Thursday's lecture will be called the
case for restraint I hope you'll be able
to join us for the whole series of these
lectures the funding for this lecture
series
comes from an anonymous donor in honor
of Henry L Stimson Yale College class of
1889 an attorney and statesman whose
government service culminated in his
tenth tenure as Secretary of War during
the Second World War since 1998 the
Macmillan Center and Yale University
Press have collaborated to bring
distinguished diplomats and foreign
policy experts to the center to lecture
on their books that are published in
this series by Yale University Press
some of the previous Stimson lectures
have included Samuel Huntington's
political order in changing societies
shellings political shellings arms and
influence the Arab Center the promise of
moderation by Marwan Masha what happened
to national liberation by Michael Walzer
and David may his imprint of Congress
I'm very pleased today to be able to
introduce professor John Mearsheimer
welcome thank you very much Ian can
everybody in the rear hear me okay I am
wired up it's a great pleasure and
honored to be here
of course I know who Henry Stimson was
what student of international security
does it and I've also long known about
the Stimson lectures because two of my
favourite books both of which Ian
mentioned Sam Huntington's book
political order and changing in
societies and Thomas Schelling is very
famous spoke arms and influence were
originally Stimpson lectures so it's a
great honor to be following in their
footsteps and before I start I'd like to
thank in very much for inviting me to be
here today
to give this lecture and then of course
to give the lectures on Wednesday and on
Thursday let me just give you a brief
overview of what I want to try and do I
want to start off with some
preliminary remarks just tell you some
stories about the book its Genesis and
so forth and so on then I want to talk
about the roots of liberal hegemony and
it'll become clear as we go along here
this is really not much of an
international relations talk the
international relations comes in the
wednesday lecture and in the Thursday
lecture what I'm going to try and do
tonight is provide background for those
subsequent lectures that'll become clear
as I go along
so as Ian said I'll be talking about the
false promise of liberal hegemony
Wednesday night and then Thursday make
the case for a more restrained foreign
policy talk a little bit about the
genesis of the book first of all when I
started this thing about ten years ago
what I really wanted to do is write a
big Theory book on the relationship
between liberalism nationalism and
realism I had written the book on
realism the tragedy of great peril
politics so I knew a lot about realism
but I didn't say much about liberalism
in that book and liberalism and realism
are the two great isms in the IR world
social constructivism critical theory
Marxism all these other isms are mildly
interesting when you strip away all the
layers of the onion it boils down to
realism versus liberalism I've spent
half my life battling with liberals
right as a good realist so I knew a lot
about that but I hadn't thought much
about liberalism in any detail and then
there's nationalism I'm a big believer
that nationalism is the most powerful
political ideology on the planet that'll
become clear as we go along here and in
the subsequent lectures I also believe
that nationalism and realism we're very
closely related
almost all realists believe in the power
of nationalism but hardly any realists
have written about nationalism and
nationalism is not incorporated into
their theories right so I started
thinking about the relationship between
realism and nationalism and of course
nationalism and liberalism and what I
wanted to do is figure out you know
theoretical way is sort of how all of
these isms fit together the problem I
ran into is I couldn't do it
I spent two years trying to write a book
on it and I couldn't do it and I
couldn't figure out how to organize it
it there was just no organizing
principle to make the book work then the
second thing is I could never figure out
what liberalism really is because the
literature is just very hard to discern
and truth be told it took me 2 to 3
years just to figure out what I'm gonna
tell you here today it may all seem
patently obvious and maybe it is to some
of you I only wish you had told me
before I spent two to three years trying
to figure it out for myself
so I had a lot of trouble figuring out
exactly what liberalism is and then I
couldn't write a book that did what I
wanted to do now there was another big
issue I cared about and that was liberal
hegemony wonderla Germany is basically
the foreign policy that the United
States has pursued since the Cold War
ended almost everybody I know agrees on
this some people use a different label
for it but I think liberal hegemony is a
fair label and it's one that many people
use it's very important to understand
that the foreign policy establishment or
would Ben Rhodes you remember Ben Rhodes
he worked for Barack Obama he called the
foreign policy establishment the blob
the blob loves liberal hegemony right
it's it's it's the approved solution for
how to conduct American foreign policy
but at the same time there's there's a
small group of foreign policy experts
who think it's a deeply flawed strategy
and I'm one of those people right I
think that liberal hegemony is a
prescription for disaster and I'll make
that clear as we go along here right but
we've never gotten much traction and to
the extent that anybody's gotten any
traction I'll talk more about this in
startled Trump because you understand
Donald Trump ran against the blob and he
got elected in
heart because American foreign policy is
a disaster zone regarding the pursuit of
liberal hegemony just for background
purposes here between 1990 and 2000 you
could argue that we did pretty well with
liberal hegemony I would argue against
that but you can make a pretty good case
but that was the heyday of liberal
hegemony and since 2000 and certainly
since 2001 everything has gone south and
the $64,000 question that's on the table
today is what went wrong
you know why is American foreign policy
in so much trouble
why was Donald Trump able to run against
liberal agenda and he ran against almost
every element of the liberal hegemonist
agenda and get elected right that's that
is the big question and my argument is
the liberalism is doomed as a foreign
policy because nationalism and realism
are more powerful forces and they
undermine liberal hegemony at every turn
and if you think about it focusing on
what happens when a state pursues a
liberal foreign policy and liberal
hegemony in particular allows me to
analyze the relationship between the
three isms so this is how I figured out
how to write a book that dealt with the
relationship between liberalism
nationalism and realism by asking the
simple question why is liberal hegemony
a flawed foreign policy so in a very
important way the organizing question in
the book is why was liberal hegemony
doomed to fail and the answer is in
large part because of nationalism and
realism and in the process of laying
this all out I deal with those three
isms so I solved my problem but it took
me a couple years my approach
my approach and this will become clear
as we go along is to drill down deep and
to try to understand liberalism at its
roots and what I really want to know to
begin with or what are its starting
assumptions about human nature I've
worked very hard here and this will
become clear as I go along which is not
to say people have to agree with me
just sort of figure out what the bedrock
is that liberalism is based on and then
figure out the principal elements of
liberalism and then try to understand
liberalism as a political ideology for a
particular country independent of how it
works in the realm of foreign policy so
what I tried to do was not get wrapped
around the axle about how liberalism
applies to foreign policy I just try to
figure out what the heck is this thing
called liberalism how do I think about
it and of course in the process as I'm
thinking about liberalism I'm trying to
think about how it relates to
nationalism and realism and this is the
table of contents of the book chapter
one is the introduction so you don't pay
much attention to that but chapter two
is on human nature chapter 3 is on
political liberalism that's liberalism
inside the black box
that's liberalism is a political system
in a country and then chapter 4 is
cracks in the liberal edifice those are
tensions potential problems with
liberalism and then it's not till
chapter 5 that I get to foreign policy
so what I've done here is I've written a
book that has eight chapters and I don't
deal with IR or foreign policy until the
fifth chapter a number of IR friends who
have read the manuscript don't like it
really because they say what are you
wasting all your time talking about
human nature and talking about
liberalism as a political ideology who
cares right I want to go right to IR and
the view that I have which I'm going to
try and lay out tonight and in the next
two lectures is that you really have to
understand liberalism at its core to
understand how it applies to foreign
policy now oh sorry I want to say a few
words about me and liberalism and then a
few words about me and nationalism I
distinguished between liberalism at home
and liberalism abroad and I thank my
lucky stars that I was born and raised
in a liberal democracy called the United
States of America I'm not anti liberal
one of the great paradoxes in this
business is virtually all of the
realists that I know are liberals in
every way Morgenthau waltz these guys
were in terms of their domestic politics
they were liberals par excellence right
but they thought liberalism is a foreign
policy was a prescription for trouble
and that's my basic view my basic view
is you have to think about liberalism at
home versus liberalism abroad so I'm not
arguing that liberalism in general is a
bad thing I like liberal democracy very
much it's not perfect by any means but
I'm glad I live in the liberal democracy
my arguments are all about liberalism
when it applies abroad I want to say
about a few words about me and
nationalism nationalism is in my opinion
the most powerful political ideology on
the planet it's no accident that the
world is populated by really nothing but
nation-states and nation-states embody
nationalism and I think at the same time
it's very important to understand that
at universities especially places like
Yale and the University of Chicago
nationalism is a bad word I'm always
amazed at how my colleagues at the
University of Chicago really lo of
nationalism it just it really rubs them
the wrong way and I understand that
nationalism has a dark side to it it has
an upside as well
as a dark side but nationalism and
liberalism and this will become clear as
we go along are two different animals
liberalism is I'll try to make clear
tonight it's all about internationalism
and universities are very international
and to illustrate this I have quote from
Jonathan Holloway who is the Dean of
Yale College that was recently in The
Washington Post this is a story in The
Washington Post called the surge in
foreign students may be crowding
Americans out of elite colleges that was
the title of the article and this was
mr. Holloway's comment we want to bring
together an incredibly diverse student
body diverse in every way if we want to
train the next generation here are the
key words of global leaders we better
have the globe here
just think about what this is saying
right this is an internationalist
version of the world and this is of
course what university is all about and
I'm perfectly content to operate in this
world I would not want universities to
become more nationalists right I think
the fact that universities are
internationalist is wonderful and I
really don't consider myself much of a
nationalist although I'm going to make
the argument that virtually every
American is a nationalist right I don't
consider myself a nationalist in a
deep-seated way right but I think in
large part that's due to the fact that
I've operated in the Academy for so long
and the Academy is very internationalist
in nature and is very uncomfortable with
the concept of nationalism but the point
I'm going to make here is that the
United States a very nationalist country
it's one of the reasons that Donald
Trump got elected president he fully
understands that he fully understands
that and if Donald Trump ever saw this
and gave a 15 minute tirade on what the
Dean said and what the title of that
article said he'd make a lot have it he
really would
right so just want to be clear that with
regard to liberalism I'm talking about
liberalism abroad not liberalism at home
and with regard to nationalism I'm not
making the argument that nationalism is
this wonderful force all the time okay
roots of liberal hegemony this is the
talk tonight as I said you got to start
with human nature remember that was my
chapter - and when you talk about human
nature really what you're asking is what
are those common traits that all
individuals have in common and by the
way this is something that the founding
fathers of liberalism paid enormous
attention to and I believe that if
you're going to think about liberalism
and nationalism you have to wrestle with
these questions and there are two big
questions the first question is are men
and women social beings above all else
or does it make more sense to emphasize
their individuality in other words are
humans fundamentally social animals who
strive hard to carve out room for their
individuality or are they individuals
who form social contracts that's
question number one question number two
second have our critical faculties
develop to the point where we can reach
Universal consensus on what defines the
good life can we agree on first
principles can we use reason are we able
to reason our way through collectively
and come to meaningful agreement on the
big questions about life those are sort
of the two big issues on the table when
you think about human nature now my
views on this subject are that human
beings are primarily social animals
we're born into societies were born into
groups and we are heavily socialized
inside those groups both by the family
and the society around us in a really
big way before our individual
individuality really gets to assert
itself I think human beings are very
tribal to put it in simplistic terms
from the get-go it's not to say that you
can't have a lot of individualism but
we're primarily social animals and
secondly I think it's impossible to come
close to reaching a universal consensus
on questions about the good life I mean
all you have to do is think about
religion do we have anything
approximating a consensus on religion
can you use your critical faculties to
prove to me the Catholicism is superior
to Protestantism or Protestantism is
superior to Catholicism and then we can
throw in all the other religions or what
if you're an atheist I don't think so
and you could point to all sorts of
other examples why does it matter so
much who's appreciate who's appointed to
the Supreme Court why do we really care
about that because we know it's the
judges opinions the judges personal
opinions that determines what the
rulings are when you're dealing with
hard cases that reach the Supreme Court
that's why the Republicans care so much
and the Democrats care so much there's
no truth there's no universal agreement
I mean they're people like Ronald
Dworkin who push in that direction but
they're outliers among legal theorists
and even at universities do we teach
moral principles do we have a body of
worrell principles that we teach to
students
I don't think so what we do is expose
students to all sorts of different
perspectives
we have no agreement on first principles
there are a few things that we agree on
but even if we do agree once you get
outside the university once you get
outside the United States the idea that
you're gonna generate meaningful
agreement agreement on what's the best
political system liberal democracy go to
Russia today and ask people what they
think of liberal democracy 1990s
that's what liberal democracy is for
them they'll take stability every time
over a liberal democracy so there's no
real consensus here this is my view and
what about liberals the liberal take on
human nature is that humans are
basically atomistic individuals the
basic story they operate as individuals
in the state of nature you know the
basic story that Hobbes who's not a
liberal but laid out many of the
founding principles of liberalism makes
and that John Locke makes that
individuals are atomistic in the state
of nature and they come together and
they form a social contract so that the
individual comes before the social and
then of course liberals believe that's
impossible to come close to reaching a
universal consensus on questions about
the good life right so I agree with the
liberal position with regard to the
second question but I disagree on the
first question whereas liberals think
individuals come before society I think
the opposite now if you put the two
liberal assumptions together about human
nature what you end up is a world where
individuals will sometimes have vehement
disagreements about first principles
right once you agree that individuals
cannot reach a consensus on first
principles and first principles involve
hot-button issues
you then are in a situation where those
disagreements might be so profound that
you'll have violent conflict so what
this tells me is that the potential for
mortal conflict since at the root of
liberalism and this of course in the
Haab story and even in the Locke story
is why you leave the state of nature and
the reason that you want to create a
state you know the rest of the story
right but the point that I'm making to
you here is when you look at the to
bedrock assumptions about individuality
and about the ability of people to use
their critical faculties to answer the
big questions of life and you look at
the liberal perspective and you put
those two assumptions together you get
significant potential for conflict and
then the question becomes how do you
prevent conflict how do you set up a
liberal society so as to avoid conflict
I just put that up there because it's
important to emphasize that when
liberalism got its start it was in large
part concerned with the consequences of
the Reformation which was that Catholics
and Protestant fought bloody wars in
countries all over Europe and again the
limits of Reason show you that you can't
answer which religion is superior but at
the same time there's no question that
people are profoundly attached to
Catholicism and hate Protestantism and
vice-versa so how do you deal with that
problem this again is the problem that
liberalism faces my argument is a
liberal solution it has three parts
first as an alien rights second is
tolerance and second is the
Nightwatchman case this is the hard core
of liberalism I'm going to make some
additional points about differences
among liberals in a few minutes but when
you talk about the liberal solution to
the problem of conflict
they're sort of three elements that come
together to in effect dampen conflict
the first is the concept of inalienable
rights what this says that is that every
individual on the planet has a set of
rights to be life liberty and property
so forth and so on but every individual
on the planet has a set of Rights that
are inalienable that nobody can take
away from that person and inalienable
rights are of enormous importance for
solving this problem because for example
if somebody has the right to life that
means you can't kill that person
somebody has Liberty life liberty
pursuit of property all these rights
everybody has those rights and you're
not supposed to interfere with them and
the second is the norm of tolerance that
should be a two and a three the norm of
tolerance and tolerance in large part
grows out of this emphasis on rights
because otherwise and rights to think
their own way right you and effect
should be tolerant so liberal societies
place a very high premium on tolerance
right in addition to rights and again
the tolerance is inextricably linked
with the rights once you have been a
label rights it'll be a big emphasis on
tolerance but the problem is because of
the vehemence of the disputes and the
fact that there is a tendency for people
when they really disagree to want to
kill each other
tolerance is not going to be enough and
therefore you need a state to act as a
night watchman right liberals believe
that you need a state it's very clear
that liberals have a mixed set of
feelings about the state in large part
because a powerful state can threaten
the individuals rights but at the same
time virtually all liberals understand
that you need a state and you need a
state to act as a night watchman because
again just to go back to square one you
have individuals out there who have
profound differences about terribly
important issues and the question is how
do you prevent people from killing each
other and again you emphasize rights you
emphasize tolerance but those two things
together are not enough you need a state
as well
now this begins to morph into the IR
issue and I want to just take a few
minutes to lay this out without getting
into the international relations
dimension of things the focus on the
individual and his or her in a Lea
Beloit's turns liberalism into a
universalistic or Universalist ideology
there's in other words is this dimension
in liberalism that grows out of its
emphasis on the individual that makes it
universal what liberalism is saying is
that every person on the planet has the
same rights those rights are universal
they apply to everybody if you focus on
social groups if you believe that human
beings are social animals first and
foremost you end up with a particular
astrology like nationalism so
nationalism doesn't focus on individuals
it focuses on the group and there is
your group and then there is the other
it's a particular estai d ology that's
not what liberalism is all about
liberalism focuses on the individual and
once you focus on the individual you
quickly and don't
the Universalist ideology when you throw
in inalienable rights and of course when
you start thinking about liberal
hegemony just to get ahead of myself
when the rights of people outside the
borders of the United States are
violated there's a very powerful
temptation to go abroad
now take this step further there are two
kinds of political liberalism one is
classical or modus vivendi liberalism
and the other is modern or progressive
liberalism I got this distinction mainly
from the writings of John Gray for
anybody who's interested he's written a
book called two phases of liberalism
which is an excellent book that lays
this out and Alan Ryan has also written
an important essay that lays this out so
what you have is you have motifs what I
call modus vivendi liberalism and
progressive liberalism and and these are
the two different forms of liberalism
that we want to think about and the
story I'm going to tell as we go along
here is the progressive liberalism has
trumped moderate modus vivendi
liberalism we wit we live in a world
where progressive liberalism dominates
and I'll lay that story out before I go
on to unpacking what modus vivendi
liberalism and progressive liberalism
are I just want to say that I
distinguish liberalism from
utilitarianism and from liberal idealism
utilitarianism is identified with people
like Jeremy Bentham and Jeremy Bentham
hated the emphasis on inalienable rights
he said it was nonsense and utilitarians
and liberals tend to be at each other's
throats in all sorts of ways if you look
at the debates between Ronald Dworkin
and Richard Posner both famous legal
theorists Dworkin is very much a
progressive liberal and Posner is very
much utilitarian and they bark at each
other use the
the language of utilitarian and liberal
if you look at John Rawls John Rawls
frequently is barking against or barking
about utilitarians so I'm not talking
about utilitarians when I talk about
liberals for those of you who do I are
in the audience and have read eh car eh
cars attack on liberalism which was
written in the 1930s is an attack on
utilitarianism and on liberal idealism
it's not an attack on the liberalism I'm
talking about car and I are going after
very different targets liberal idealism
by the way is identified with people
like th green and John Dewey I won't go
into any details on what exactly it is
but it's a very different animal than
the liberalism I'm talking about and I'm
not saying these two are irrelevant or
not worth studying but not what I'm
looking at I'm looking to progressive
liberalism and modus vivendi liberalism
both of which focus in large part on
rights ok now I want to do is I want to
distinguish between these two kinds of
liberalism
right and you want to remember that this
is the hard core so there's no question
that both progressives and modus vivendi
liberals emphasize those three elements
now in distinguishing between the two
kinds of liberalism first point I would
make is it's not the difference that's
based on reason they're actually some
progressive liberals who make the
argument that we can use our critical
faculties to figure out questions about
the good life and actually the piece
that comes the closest to making this
argument is Francis Fukuyama's very
famous piece on the end of history if
you go back and read Francis Fukuyama's
piece after listen to my talk tonight
what Francis Fukuyama is basically
saying in that piece is that with the
end of the Cold War we've reached the
end of history we're not going to have
any more conflict we're not going to
have any more war
because we're not going to have any more
disagreements on big questions he's
basically saying liberal democracy 1 and
from here on out the planet is going to
be covered by more and more liberal
democracies until we have nothing but
liberal democracies and liberal
democracies never have anything to fight
over it's all been settled that's his
argument but he's really the only person
that makes that argument and if you look
at his book he backtracks in the book ok
so my initial inclination when I started
studying liberalism was to think that
there was a difference between
progressive liberals and modus vivendi
liberals that involved reason but I
don't believe that anymore I think there
are two big differences the first big
difference is between negative and
positive rights and the desirability and
efficacy of social engineering now
you're saying yourself what exactly is
he talking about when we talk about
negative rights we're talking about you
know Liberty we're talking about freedom
from state interference we're talking
about free speech freedom of assembly
the right to property right this is
where you have a state that just
protects your freedoms right positive
rights or where the state actually
interferes to guarantee that you enjoy
rights that are inalienable and I think
the best example of this and I'll talk
more about it as we go along is the
right to equal opportunity if you look
at John Rawls and you look at Ronald
Dworkin they talked a great deal about
justice and justice for them is all
about equal opportunity and equal
opportunity is where the state comes in
and it levels the playing field it's not
equal outcomes it's
equal-opportunity right and needless to
say if you believe in positive rights
you're going to believe in the
desirability of social engineering
because there's no way you can put
positive rights into effect without
doing a lot of social engineering just
to get ahead of myself a bit if you're
doing negative rights only right all you
want is a state as a night watchman here
we go
modus vivendi liberals modus vivendi
liberals this is Friedrich Hayek for
anybody who really wants to sort of read
a canonical version of modus vivendi
liberalism read Friedrich Hayek I think
Locke fits in the same rough category
negative rights over positive rights
modus vivendi are classical liberals
really dislike positive rights I think
it's fair to say Hayek hates positive
rights he thinks the state should not be
doing social engineering they low cent
social engineering they make the
argument almost all of them that not
only is it not desirable but we're not
good at it and that's why we shouldn't
do it you know all the arguments
Republicans make these arguments all the
time that we should let the market
decide how to solve problem X or solve
problem Y because markets are much more
efficient than the state when the state
gets involved doing anything it bollocks
is it up that's the classical liberal
the modus vivendi liberal view
progressive liberals on the other hand
they believe in negative rights because
everybody believes Udeid the
Nightwatchman to protect those liberties
but progressive liberals also believe
that it's very important for the state
to get involved to do social engineering
to create a level playing field right
there are all these positive rights it's
like just just think about medical care
or healthcare do we believe in health
care in the United States I think the
answer is yes I think if you look at the
Republicans they can't just kill
Obamacare they have to replace Obamacare
because I think we've reached the point
and I could go into this greater detail
and the Q & A of people well we've
reached the point where basically
everybody believes that people have a
right to the universal health care or
right to health care right but once you
start talking about a right to health
care you're talking about positive
rights right the states involved in
social engineering and of course this is
why Republicans dislike Obamacare
because the Republicans talk like
classical liberals although I'll make
the argument in the short time that they
act like progressive liberals you see
that's the difference between modus
vivendi liberals and progressives
liberals it's not that one believes that
you can use your critical faculties to
reach conclusions about first principles
and the other doesn't
I thought that initially but no I think
that modus vivendi liberals and
progressive liberals have a difference
about rights right
they have a difference about rights a
difference on social engineering now my
argument is that with the passage of
time progressive liberalism has Trump's
modus vivendi liberalism or classical
liberalism not at the rhetorical level
but in practice and let me just say a
little bit about this we have in the
United States a remarkably powerful
state that intervenes in almost all
aspects of our life it's involved in
heavy-duty social engineering and
there's no way you can get around that
and the Republicans just to talk about
this in some detail the Republicans
constantly talk about how terrible this
is and how they want to change things
and how when they get elected we're
going to let the market do this
we're gonna stop the government from
doing that we're gonna get out of the
business of doing social engineering but
if you look at how Republicans behave in
contrast the Democrats there's hardly
any difference at all there's no
evidence the Democrats spend more money
on social engineering the Republicans do
there's no evidence that Democrats
create more institutions then
Republicans do the Republicans created
the Department of Homeland Security the
Republicans created the Environmental
Protection Agency Ronald Reagan spent
one heck of a lot more money on social
issues than Barack Obama did and even in
cases where Democrats outspent
Republicans you look at different
presidents it's by tiny margins so
there's just not much difference at all
there is one political party in the
United States that actually truly
believes in modus vivendi liberalism
it's represented by the libertarian
party libertarians are classical
liberals or modus vivendi liberals no
single no single libertarian has ever
been elected to Congress and in the 2016
presidential election the libertarian
received a little over three percent of
the vote so the idea that we have a
political party that really represents
modus vivendi liberalism and stands a
chance of winning is erroneous it's
impossible the Republican Party and the
Democratic Party despite all the
rhetoric committed to progressive
liberalism that's to say they're deeply
committed to social engineering and
they're deeply committed to positive
rights you can make the argument that
the Democratic Party is more committed
than the Republican Party to positive
rights maybe so but the Republican Party
is also committed to positive rights
now why is this the case it really all
began at least in the United States in
the late 1800s and it's a function of
three things one is the Industrial
Revolution to his nationalism and three
is these huge Wars that we fight just on
the Industrial Revolution what happened
when the United when the United States
really was hit hard with the Industrial
Revolution in the late 19th early 20th
century as you had these huge industrial
enterprises that came online that did
certain things that had huge
consequences for people all over the
United States and indeed for people all
over the planet and it became very
obvious to politicians at the time and
here we're talking about Republicans
because you understand that the original
progressives in the United States were
not Democrats they were mainly
Republicans Herbert Hoover was a social
engineer par excellence
Teddy Roosevelt was a social engineer
par excellence right and the reason was
that you had to manage this economy you
had to manage these huge industries and
figure out rules and regulations you had
all sorts of labor unions labor problems
child labor problems and so forth and so
on that had to be managed by the state
there's no way you could avoid that and
then of course when you start fighting
wars whether it's the American Civil War
World War One World War two the state
gets involved not only in running those
wars but when the wars are over with you
have to do all sorts of social
engineering to reward the people who
fought the wars you remember the GI Bill
the GI Bill is a perfect example of a
positive right it's social engineering I
could go on and on about this right and
then there's nationalism of course which
I'll talk much more about next time
right we start thinking about
nationalism what happens is that the
state has all sorts of reasons
to want to organize people down below
for administrative reasons for economic
reasons for military reasons the state
gets in the business of doing social
engineering in a big way right when you
think about nationalism the state is
interested in creating a coherent nation
and it wants that nation to be loyal to
the state that involves doing all sorts
of things of an administrative nature
again of an economic nature and a
military nature and of course with
nationalism people in the nation have a
certain loyalty to the state this is the
nation state the nation has loyalty to
the state and the end result of that is
that the state is expected to do things
for the nation for the people and of
course your if you're in a liberal
democracy like the United States
politicians who promise to do all sorts
of things for people tend to get elected
over those who promise not to do big
things for people so in a liberal nation
state like the United States that
undergoes the Industrial Revolution then
fights big Wars fool those reasons you
move into a world where progressive
liberalism dominates and again
progressive liberalism is all about
positive rights and it's about social
engineering so here's the modern liberal
template core assumptions individualism
no universal agreement on first
principles okay those are the two
starting assumptions I had about human
nature second progressive liberalism has
triumphed and with progressive
liberalism you get negative and positive
and alienable rights those are
inalienable rights those positive rights
as well as those negative rights give
tolerance and you get a state that
engages in social engineering that's the
basic liberal story now how does this
apply to IR just to get ahead of myself
there are two very important dimension
to this story one I've already
emphasized and that's the individualism
right
it's the individualism and the
inalienable rights that creates the
Universalist dimension cannot
underestimate the importance of this
liberals and is certainly true in
countries like the United States and
Britain tend to see people who live in
other countries as having the same
rights as them and because they play
such a high premium on rights liberalism
is all about rights really matter when
the rights of those people are being
violated in a serious way needless to
say it's gonna create a very powerful
incentive to see if you can fix that
problem and if you're the United States
of America and you are super powerful
it's not surprising that you're going to
be at least tempted to fix the problem
right so again that focus on
individualism is so important right
married to Italia belies the second
thing that really matters for the
international relations dimension of my
story is the social engineering once you
accept the fact the progressive
liberalism has triumphed and that we
live in a world where liberals are
committed to social engineering and by
the way even if you were deliberately
you'd have to be committed to social
engineering just given the complexities
of moderns of the modern world
whether it's a liberal state or not it's
going to be an interventionist state at
home but this liberal state called the
United States is heavily into social
engineering but if you're into social
engineering at home it doesn't take long
before you think you can do social
engineering abroad I remember the Iraq
war which I adamantly and publicly
opposed before it happened and I would
say to people do you seriously believe
that you're going to go into Iraq
and through social engineering in a
country that you really don't understand
we can't even do social engineering at
home much less in foreign country but
I'll tell you those boys and girls who
took us in they were very confident that
they could do social engineering there
are Americans these were skilled
thinkers these were people who knew how
to do business right so we went
traipsing into Iraq and of course you
know what happened which is what I'll
talk about it next time right but the
point is when you unpack the liberal
story right what you see is this next
lecture next lecture what I want to do
is I want to explain logic behind
liberal hegemony I've obviously told you
part of the story but I want to unpack
it in even greater detail in other words
the story tonight is basically about
liberalism and its roots and liberalism
as a political ideology inside a state
right I want to explain liberal hegemony
then I want to provide evidence that it
does not work as advertised
indeed it leads to untold trouble I want
to talk about NATO expansion NATO
expansion was liberal hegemony at work
nothing to do with realism I want to
talk about the Bush Doctrine in the
Middle East and I want to just show you
how much trouble we've had and then I
want to explain why liberal hegemony
fails I want to explain what went wrong
with NATO expansion I want to explain
what went wrong in the greater Middle
East right and of course you're not
going to be surprised to hear that my
story is all about how nationalism and
realism wort liberalism that's my basic
story and of course all of this is to
say that I in a very interesting way
ended up in the end dealing with
nationalism realism and liberalism and
comparing those three isms although when
I started the book I couldn't figure out
a way to do that here at the end I did
it now whether I succeeded or not you'll
tell me tonight and on
and on Thursday thank you
[Music]